[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings as
russia increases its attacks on
ukrainian cities there is a growing
international push to charge russia's
leaders with war crimes the list of
alleged violations includes the bombing
of a maternity hospital the shelling of
residential areas and an attack on a
nuclear power plant
russian president vladimir putin is
among those who potentially could be
charged senior investigative
correspondent catherine harris reports
the evidence could come together rapidly
however getting a conviction would be
hard indeed catherine good morning
good morning tony our investigative team
found the russian aggression in ukraine
is so severe and events unfolding so
rapidly that a war crimes case could
come together quickly as a warning the
video in this report is graphic and may
be disturbing to some people
beyond the indiscriminate shelling of
civilian targets and the mortar attack
on fleeing families vladimir putin
crossed a perilous threshold when a
russian assault set off a fire at
europe's largest nuclear reactor this is
the most direct case really since since
world war ii of having a certainly a
great power
engaging in this kind of attack on the
civilian population stephen rapp is a
former u.s ambassador at large for war
crimes who's built cases against
dictators and sought accountability for
genocide how will investigators build a
war crimes case against the russian
president the first way that they can
build it and it may be sufficient in
this case
they can look at the pattern of the
attack
if there is a war crimes designation
against vladimir putin what would it
mean well it would mean that he's an
international pariah it also means that
he can't travel anywhere
no more summits
because he'd be putting himself in
danger the u.s embassy in kyiv called
the attack on the nuclear plant a war
crime but hours later the white house
dialed back the language we have not
made conclusions it's a legal review and
a process that goes through the
administration so the bar is very high
it's very high but just given the
intensity of this campaign and the
civilian destruction i think that can be
developed in a matter of weeks the
international criminal court's chief
prosecutor karim khan has opened an
investigation into russia's conduct in
ukraine the u.s is not part of the court
which has a track record of 10
convictions over two decades securing
justice there does not happen quickly
the court had to pull the arrest warrant
for libyan leader muammar gaddafi after
he was executed by his own people and
syria's president bashar al-assad
remains in power nearly a decade after
he allegedly used chemical weapons
against the syrian people is there any
past indication that vladimir putin
cares about being branded a war criminal
i don't think so matthew cranig worked
the russia and nuclear portfolios under
the bush obama and trump administrations
he told cbs news there's a rising threat
from russia's stockpile of lower yield
weapons known as tactical nukes these
are weapons that would be used for
winning a battle
on the field in ukraine is the use of a
tactical nuclear weapon against
civilians a war crime yes a war crime of
the highest order this week intelligence
officials warned of a russian policy
called escalate to de-escalate we
obviously take it very seriously that
allows for the use of smaller tactical
nuclear weapons on the battlefield to
intimidate an adversary i think before
he lost the war he would try to use
nuclear weapons to try to pull victory
from the jaws of defeat some people
listening to that may say that you're
being an alarmist
are you being an alarmist well i think
the risk of nuclear war is still low but
i think the risk is higher now than any
time we've seen in in recent years
when you hear those sirens where does
your heart take you well it always takes
me uh to the side of those people that
are there and to families whose children
are dying and obviously it always
motivates me to say what can we do to to
bring that guy in yesterday at the state
department briefing a spokesman said
they've seen credible reporting of
deliberate attacks on civilians which
would under the geneva conventions
constitute a war crime though not part
of the international criminal court the
spokesman said the u.s is gathering
evidence for a possible prosecution dana
all right catherine and as you reminded
us in the piece the difference between
that charge and then actual
accountability or punishment thank you